[Dr. John Neff:] My name is Dr. John Neff, Assistant Professor of Pediatrics at Johns Hopkins.
It is my feeling that it is no longer necessary
to perform routine preschool or infant smallpox vaccinations.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I'm Samuel Katz, Professor and Chairman of the Department of Pediatrics at Duke University.
I believe that our nation's freedom from smallpox
rests upon the widespread use of smallpox vaccine.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] I'm Dr. Paul Wehrle. It is my job today to try to resolve these two opposed points of view.
[Music]
[Host:] Welcome to the exploration of concepts
and controversies in modern medicine,
one of a series of programs dedicated to examining
the uncertain,
candidly recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon opinion,
and that the opinions of eminent physicians
in a given field vary widely.
The National Medical Audiovisual Center believes
that openly airing such opposing views
is a basic responsibility of medical communications.
Dr. Paul Wehrle, Hastings Professor of Pediatrics at the University Of Southern California
School of Medicine, will act as moderator for this presentation.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] For many years the physicians of this country and the workers in public health
have been emphasizing the need for vaccination for children,
and particularly infants and preschool children,
to provide a basic immunity against smallpox.
We also have been urging immunization at intervals
for particular types of health workers,
for transportation workers, and at intervals
we have also urged reimmunization of all citizens
of this country, whether they plan international travel or not.
The immunization against smallpox is the earliest and one of the most effective prophylaxis
agents against any of the communicable diseases.
However, during recent years the ballgame
seems to be changed,
the rules are somewhat different, and perhaps
there are differences with respect to some
of the threats.
I would first like to, before getting our
combatants into the fray,
I'd like to first turn to see what's happening
with regard to the international picture
and see what's happening to smallpox on the
worldwide scale because I think this is important
to us as we develop our story today.
As you'll see, in 1945 smallpox was present
throughout virtually all of South America.
1945 you will note is the lighter, shaded
together with the darker shaded areas
spread throughout all of South America,
throughout all of Africa, through the Middle
East, through Southeast Asia,
and down including Malaya
and many of the countries in the South Pacific.
During the next period of time, from 1955
through 1965,
we see additional changes taking place.
Here the earlier period is in lighter color,
the subsequent period in darker color,
and here you see that these areas originally
involved very solidly
have become substantially smaller,
and I think it's important to note that the
areas involved here,
although they are solidly colored,
may have some differences with respect to
specific areas within those countries where
smallpox remains a problem.
Also, another area that I hope we can point
up today is data concerning the risk of vaccination
should it be introduced into this country.
I think at this time I would like to turn
to our first combatant this morning,
Dr. Neff, and see how he would like to develop
his particular position.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, I think that there can
be no question now that smallpox vaccination
has been the one agent
which has been responsible for eradicating
smallpox from large areas of the world.
But I think there can be no question also
that by present-day standards,
smallpox vaccine, or as a vaccine, is a very
poor vaccine.
And I think for two reasons it's a poor vaccine.
For one reason, the duration of immunity that is afforded by the smallpox vaccination is
relatively short in duration
and probably absolute immunity
to smallpox from the vaccine is no longer
than three years.
Number two, there are a significant number
of complications that are associated
with this particular vaccine,
and a significant amount of mortality.
Now, for a long time in this country we've
practiced routine preschool and infant vaccinations
so that within this country about 90 percent
of the people have been vaccinated at least
at least one time in their life.
And it's also true since 1949 there've been
no cases of smallpox imported into the United States.
But for this we've paid a real price.
Based on surveys that we've done in 1968 and
1963, and review of the death certificates,
there can be no question that there are at
least seven deaths a year
as a result of our smallpox vaccination policy.
And the other question that this brings up,
has this really been the reason
that we have been free of smallpox?
If you look carefully in terms of the immunity
of the nation,
you'll find that 80 percent of the population
has not been vaccinated within three years
and therefore are not absolutely protected
against smallpox,
and 50 percent have not been vaccinated for
greater than 15 years
and probably have little or no protection
at all from smallpox.
Whereas the epidemiology of smallpox is such that this can be prevented
from entering into our country,
and I think has been, not because our population
has been well-vaccinated,
but because our travelers are well-vaccinated.
And I think that the other thing is that it
is a very focal disease
and that secondary cases can be predicted
and they're not going to sweep through the
nation as other diseases,
perhaps measles or whatnot.
But it's the secondary cases are very focal
and occur in hospital personnel and family contact.
And I think that all we have to do in this
country is number one, immunize our travelers
and that will keep smallpox out and number
two, identify those risks,
those populations at high-risk and those are
your hospital personnel and your family contacts.
And it is not necessary to perform routine
smallpox vaccination.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Thank you Dr. Neff. I think you've summed up the arguments very nicely here.
and I think at this point we should turn to
Dr. Sam Katz
and see what he has to say concerning the
need to continue our present position.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I think that it's important
to recall that a little over 30 years ago,
there were at least 15,000 cases of smallpox
in the United States.
And that as Dr. Neff has pointed out, we have had
none basically over the last 20 years.
This is an admirable record, and it's one
which I think we all wish to persist and defend.
The question which is basic to this is weighing
a known dimension against the conjecture.
We agree, I think, Dr. Wehrle, Dr. Neff and
I, that much of this admirable record stems
from the widespread use of vaccine.
We cannot provide any data on what would happen if we abandoned this widespread immunization program.
We can look at the experience in other countries.
In 1948 Great Britain abandoned the legal
compulsion of smallpox vaccination.
Over subsequent years they've had hundreds of cases of smallpox, which have resulted from importation
and in this regard I would disagree with Dr.
Neff that the vaccination of our travelers
will protect us against importations,
because in most cases, it has not been natives
returning to their nation who have brought
the initial case,
it has been a native of a country in which
the disease remains endemic,
as shown on Dr. Wehrle's chart.
In this regard then, I think we cannot close
the door
and rely solely upon the immunization of our
travelers.
I think we have to accept the fact that we
can't control a great deal of the population
and that in the jet age it's very simple for
a person to be incubating smallpox,
come from Asia, Africa, or Brazil to the United
States with no overt disease,
and introduce the disease within a very short
period of time.
The other feature is, I think our physicians
are unable to recognize the disease anymore
because we're free of it.
So this reliance on quick smothering of an
outbreak is, I think, a bit optimistic
under present circumstances.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] I think that Dr. Katz has
summed up very nicely many of the arguments
for continuing our present policies
and I think we have several points that we
ought to discuss in depth
in order to bring out some of these divergent
types of opinions.
Now, the first question that I think we might
bounce around a bit concerns the probability
of introducing smallpox
into the United States with our present surveillance
systems, with our present levels of immunization
and so on.
And I think the Communicable Disease Center
in Atlanta,
a number of other organizations such as World
Health Organization,
the governments and health services of many
other countries,
have studied this problem very carefully.
John, you seem to minimize the risk of bringing
smallpox in,
via either Americans abroad or nationals from
other countries.
[Dr. John Neff:] Yes, well I think the important
point here,
and I would disagree with Dr. Katz,
it's not the nationals of another country,
but it's generally the nationals of the country
to which smallpox is introduced.
I think one of the reasons is that smallpox
now in the present pattern of eradication
is being driven back into relatively remote
areas.
And it is not the cities and it's not the
travelers that have a tendency
to come in contact with cases of smallpox,
and I think that one can look at our own history
for the past 20 years.
Our protection has not prevented smallpox
from spreading in the United States,
actually we've never been challenged.
We haven't had an importation into the United
States.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] How do you know we haven't
been challenged?
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, this is a good question.
I think that we have a very good surveillance
system at the CDC,
at the national CDC, and any suspected case
is looked at by a person
who is capable of diagnosing smallpox and
differentiating this from chickenpox.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I can't agree with that
now, John.
I think you can be honest about this without
denigrating the medical profession.
We have not had the experience in this country
looking at smallpox.
Even the best physicians acquainted with tropical
medicine would be perfectly frank to say that
a bad case of chickenpox
is impossible to differentiate from a mild
or a more severe case of smallpox.
I think we can all recall a few years ago
when this was exactly what happened,
when a lady from Ghana was thought to have
smallpox and actually had Varicella.
Secondly, that emphasized the fact that our
laboratory facilities,
though they may in rare instances be attuned
to this, are not constantly challenged with
making the diagnosis of smallpox,
so that there can be confusion even with the
laboratory support that's required
for the diagnosis, in a country where smallpox
is not occurring.
So I have no peace of mind about our ability
to diagnosis smallpox
either clinically or laboratory-wise
at the drop of a hat in New York, San Francisco, Seattle, Boston, any port where the disease
might enter tomorrow.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Well, this is certainly
an area where I think we might remain far apart.
I wonder if there are a two or three things
that we could agree with here now?
Certainly we haven't had any widespread occurrence of  smallpox
in this country for many years.
We're agreed on this point, we agree.
Now it is possible that a case or two cases
or an occasional case, one or two, three a year,
something like this, may come into the country, may occur without spread,
could conceivably misdiagnosis.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I would say this again,
it's only conjecture, but to me, if I wanted
to use such conjecture I would use it to reinforce
the concept that
if this is happening periodically, our level
of immunization has been sufficient to dampen
the spread of disease.
I don't like John's use of the word a poor
vaccine.
There are problems with smallpox vaccine.
I think there is good work going on to improve
the vaccine.
But this business of three years and prevention
of disease is one thing,
prevention of death is the other.
You're emphasizing death as your big fear
with smallpox vaccine.
I think you must emphasize death as your fear
with the disease.
Now the mortality rate with importation in
Europe has been anywhere from 10 to 40 percent
in various outbreaks.
As far as protection from smallpox vaccine
is concerned,
if memory serves me correctly, if you've had
immunization even within 20 years,
though you may get disease, there has not
been mortality from the disease.
And I think in the long run that's our best
protection,
is against death from the disease.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, let me mention something
here,
I think that when you're talking about the
deaths secondary to smallpox vaccine,
that you're talking in the range of seven a year,
which means over the 20 years that we
have been free of smallpox,
we've had probably in the range of 100 to
200 deaths as the result of the vaccine.
It would take an awfully large epidemic of
smallpox to be able to equal that mortality.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Well John, before we get
into that area, let's clear up one or two
points where I think we have some real problems.
One of them is in the area of the real effectiveness
of this vaccine,
and Dr. Katz indicated that the immunity as
far as death is concerned seems to be pretty solid.
For at least 20 or 25 years after vaccination,
death would be unusual.
Cases do occur, but there is some protection
still conferred.
After 10, 15, 20 or even 25 years you have
a diminished risk of acquiring the disease,
although for three years or something like
that it's virtually solid.
This really is a pretty good vaccine.
I think what you meant was a poor vaccine
in terms of hazards in comparison with benefits
in this particular frame, in this country.
[Dr. John Neff:] Right, and I think if you
are just going to look at that aspect alone,
then I think it would be very surprising if
this particular vaccine
passed the stringent regulations that we have
for a vaccine.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Well, let's look at the
deaths that occur.
It seems to me that as we examine them, and
this is from Dr. Neff's own publications,
[laughter]
that at least 50 percent of them are in a
true sense preventable.
That is, individuals receive smallpox vaccine
for whom we know it is an untoward immunization procedure,
a child with eczema or the sibling of a child with eczema, a patient with a malignancy
involving the immune mechanism,
the patient on immunosuppressive drugs,
these are patients we know will have trouble with smallpox vaccine,
these latter ones, or any live-virus vaccine.
This is an accident of medical supervision
or of public health supervision.
I don't think the vaccine should be incriminated
on this basis,
rather we should incriminate ourselves as
having poor judgment in using it improperly.
As far as the children are concerned with
eczema, I think we're aware
that there are efforts to improve
and to come up with a strain of vaccinia that might not cause eczema vaccinatum.
But I would again get back to the point of
blanketing importations.
It seems to me that the sort of crash program
you have, when suddenly the news hits that
a case of smallpox has been imported,
you're more apt to get poor discrimination in the use of vaccine
as you get the panic situation,
run around and vaccinate everyone who might
have been exposed...
it seems to me there you're in a situation where you're more likely
to immunize the inappropriate individuals
than you are in an ongoing program where good
judgment can be encouraged.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, there are two things
that you bring up.
One is the preventability of the complications.
And Sam, I have taken your stand in the past,
that a large number of these complications are preventable.
But the thing that bothers me is that when you actually look at the complications that occur,
that could be preventable, this has been known
a long time,
that you shouldn't vaccinate a child with
eczema or a family contact with eczema,
yet at the same time between 1963 and 1968
when there's been a lot of publicity,
you still have the same number of cases of
eczema vaccinata.
The same can be said about vaccinating people
with any type of immunological deficiency disease.
But the difference between '63 and '68 in
the data when you would hopefully see a reduction,
there seems to be no change and it's just
an accident, I think,
of practice that some of these people get
vaccinated.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] Well then, you're willing to take that inevitability of change and bargain that
against the unknown factor of all right, we're defeated, we can't alter that, is what you're
saying basically.
Are you then willing to bargain from the unknown,
which is the only way to prevent those few
deaths, which are tragic, I agree,
but the only way to prevent it is then to
take the gamble, which we can't provide any data on
of how many cases of smallpox would we have,
were we to do away with routine immunization
and how many cases of these same complications
would we have in the use of crash program vaccinations?
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] This brings up a very interesting
point
that I think we ought to try to cover in our
next session here.
I think one is why hasn't there been a decrease,
because everyone knows that you shouldn't
vaccinate a child with eczema,
and why are we continuing to have this same
frequency of involvement here?
I think another thing that I'd like to see
you two spar over is,
is there really a greater risk in vaccinating
the individual
who has a primary vaccination as an adolescent
or as a young adult?
Because here is another part of the argument
and I think an important part.
If, for example, you're going have an unusually
high risk of complications
in vaccinating young adults for overseas travel,
for whatever,
then whatever position we take I think has
to take that part into consideration.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I think your implication,
I would accept it to support my argument,
[laughter]
we do from the Netherlands, we do from other countries
where those complications that are not preventable,
encephalitis would be the one we would say, maybe we can prevent eczema vaccinatum.
We don't know enough about post-vaccinal encephalitis
to even discuss its pathogenesis.
We don't know how to prevent it.
We do have at least data which suggest that the older the age group having their primary experience,
the more likely one is to encounter post-vaccinal encephalitis.
I would certainly use that as an argument in favor of continuing childhood or infant immunizations.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well Sam, I think that you've got to talk about the figures
that come from the United States because there's a tremendous amount of discrepancy in terms of...
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] We don't have the data
from the United States.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, I think we do, Sam,
to some degree.
It's true that right now about 90 percent
of your adults have been vaccinated,
so you see very few primary.
But over the past 20 years since the Second
World War,
about 10 percent of your military recruits
are primary vaccinees
and this comes to about two million military
recruits that have been vaccinated.
And it happens to be that there have been
no reported cases of post-vaccinal encephalitis
since the Second World War in that group.
Now it's possible that maybe one or two have
been missed,
but you certainly don't have the same type
of experience
that they've been having in the Netherlands where one per thousand times...
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] What is this data now again on how many are truly primary vaccinees?
[Dr. John Neff:] About 10 percent, Sam, 10
to 13 percent.
So that if you work this out over a 20 year period,
it comes in the range of 20 million primary vaccinations
in a system where you have pretty good surveillance
for complications.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] I can't quite follow how
you're getting 20 million,
[Dr. John Neff:] I'm sorry, two million. Excuse
me, Sam, two million.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] Yeah, yeah.
If you turn around the other way, of course
your statistics on the severe complications
in childhood amount to about one per million.
[Dr. John Neff:] That's right.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] And of those, one, we would
say 50 percent perhaps are preventable,
so it's a half of one per million which brings
it down to probably the same rate
I think you're bargaining for.
[Dr. John Neff:] Well, it's variable.
I think that it's at least a half per million.
In 1963 there were five post-vaccinal encephalitis
for six million primary,
so this is merely one per million primary
vaccinations.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] And this was for primary,
presumably in young age
[Dr. John Neff:] Right.
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Individuals, symptoms.
[Dr. John Neff:] Right, particularly.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] Well, I would certainly
submit that we have difficulty in transposing
data from one nation to another,
but I'm tremendously impressed with the reliability
of the data from the Netherlands with their experience
with armed forces groups who did not have
immunization against smallpox in childhood,
and their data is certainly very striking
as to the difference in incidence of post-vaccinal
encephalitis when groups in their late teens
or early 20s are first immunized.
I don't know that we have that sort of experience
in an ongoing prospective fashion.
They've directed attention to this, as we know Dr. Vandenorder [?]
and his associates have followed this carefully.
I don't know that we've had any such careful surveillance.
[Dr. John Neff:] No, but I think that say,
in Great Britain, there has been careful surveillance
and for, their experience is very much analogous
to what our experience has been.
And theirs for revaccinees, uh, for primary
vaccinees in the adults
it's in the range of 2.8 cases of post-vaccinal
encephalitis per million,
so this is a little bit more than we have
here,
but it's at least in our ballpark rather than
the Netherlands.
So it depends on what countries' data you
quote,
and I think that when we're making these decisions
you have to look at your own country
and make the decisions as best you can based
on our experience.
[Dr. Samuel Katz:] It puts us back in the
same place, if we look to our country,
we can only look for conjectures or extrapolations.
We don't have the comparative data.
I suppose the question we're asking one another
is do we want to acquire it?
Are we at a point where we can justify a change
which will provide us with the data?
Are we too concerned about sticking pat the
way we are?
Or are we going to get in trouble if we try
the other way?
[Dr. Paul Wehrle:] Thank you, Dr. Katz, for summarizing very nicely the various
points of view and information
behind the present position regarding the
use of this vaccine.
And thank you, Dr. Neff, for doing a beautiful
job
in summarizing the arguments toward changing
our position.
I think that we, in considering the present
posture with regard to the use of vaccinia
and the prevention of smallpox as a routine
procedure in this country,
must keep these various points that have been
very ably presented very firmly in mind.
One part of the argument revolves around the
likelihood of introduction of smallpox cases
into this country
and the probability of spread once introduced.
The data here I think are quite clear, in
that it seems unreasonable to assume that
this is going to be something
that will be happening frequently in the future.
However, the chance occurrence still remains
a possibility.
The second area that was brought out, I think
very nicely by our combatants,
is the problem of a risk associated with the
use of this most effective vaccine.
A number of patients have developed,
and they can be expected to continue to develop,
serious complications.
Another considerable risk that I think was
very important to bring out is what will happen
if we no longer immunize infants and are immunizing
only those
adults who are involved in international travel
and other situations that might put them at
risk.
Thank you very much for the opportunity to
be with you.
[Host:] We thank Dr. Samuel Katz, Dr. John
Neff, and Dr. Paul Wehrle
for their interesting analysis of a critical
problem in patient care.
In subsequent programs we shall continue to
record
equally significant concepts and controversies
in modern medicine.
The opinions expressed on this program do
not necessarily constitute endorsement
by the Department of Health, Education and Welfare, the Public Health Service, or its constituents.
[Music]